the long-term budget of the EU the MFF  is set to take effect in 2021 MEP s want  to make research innovation and  digitalization new priorities in three  years alone EU member states lost around  5.1 billion euros in tax revenue just  from Google and Facebook the Parliament  voted for stronger rules and attacks on  digital companies  two out of three consumers in the EU  don't buy products online because of  high cross-border delivery costs so MEP  has adopted a proposal to make them more  transparent an estimated twenty six  point four billion euros is wasted every  year in unnecessary military expenses  Parliament is ready to start  negotiations with EU states to fund a  joint military program the sudden  promotion of Martin cel mare from head  of cabinet for Jean Claude younger to  secretary-general of the European  Commission was met with a barrage of  criticism 33m ep's spoke out against the  appointment